xavier cantat bonsoir bonsoir dont vous
êtes le frère aîné de bertrand cantat
vous avez un an de plus que lui vous
avez 41 ans vous êtes photographe et
vous publiez un livre qui s'appelle mais
fait divers journal d'un frère chez
michalon alors avant de parler de votre
livre je voulais rappeler les livres qui
sont déjà sortis sur le drame de vilnius
comme on a appelé la faire il ya marie
ma fille de nadine trintignant
trois cent mille exemplaires un
véritable réquisitoire contre contre
votre frère dont l'avocat de votre frère
d'ailleurs à demander que la sortie soit
repoussé après le procès mais sans
succès voilà alors l'autre livre
s'appelle mort à vilnius c'est un livre
de frédéric vézard et stéphane boucher
du parisien qui est sorti quinze jours
avant l'ouverture du procès alors on
reviendra sur ces deux livres on va
commencer par le vôtre mais fait divers
journal d'un frère chez michalon alors
pour vous xavier pas question de
justifier
l'acte de bertrand cantat mais
simplement de remettre les pendules à
l'heure c'est à dire que vous dites que
chaque fois que vous avez apporté des
correctifs aux médias ils les ont jamais
diffusé donc vous avez choisi d'utiliser
un autre moyen
oui c'est ça
il est évidemment pas question de
justifier
quoi que ce soit dans les coups que
bertrand a porté à marie sage et l'est
toujours dit dans chaque interview que
j'ai pu accorder
ces gestes là
ne sont pas acceptables bon ça c'est
clair voilà on revient pas dessus c'est
une évidence
par contre j'ai pas et donc je n'ai pas
du tout écrit ce livre pour dire il est
innocent c'est pas vrai c'est pas lui
marie s'est pris les pieds dans le tapis
ça n'a rien à voir ni pour justifier le
fait qu'on a le droit de battre
quelqu'un qui est en train
éventuellement de péter les plombs
en revanche moi ce à quoi je me souviens
intéressés par ce que parce que j'ai pas
eu le choix je me suis retrouvé dans la
tourmente c'est au traitement de la
faire il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup
de dysfonctionnements de la part de la
police lituanienne de la part de la
justice lituanienne de la part de ce que
je vais appeler la partie adverse et de
la part
d'un certain nombre de journalistes un
jour nos deux médias d'organes de presse
voire même deux groupes de presse ouais
donc je lundi 28 juillet 2003 lorsque
vous apprenez ce qui s'est passé à
vilnius vous êtes en vacances dans l'île
de ré avec votre femme et vos trois fils
votre portable et couper ses téléphones
de la maison qu'il sonne et très peu de
gens ce numéro est un très vieil ami qui
vous appelle et vous dit quoi
me pose une question saluer xavier c'est
cjp c'est bon c'est mon plus vieux pote
je le dis dans le bouquin on a fait mai
68 ensemble à la maternelle
c'est vraiment un très très proche donc
lui il a le numéro il a essayé de me
joindre ailleurs avant lui connaît ce
numéro là la première qu'il me pose une
question il dit est ce qu il ya
longtemps que tu as eu des nouvelles de
bertrand et je suis un peu embarrassé je
m'attendais pas du tout à ce camp de
téléphone pour me poser ce genre de
questions et je lui dis oui non en
bredouillant parce que oui et non ça
devait faire à peu près trois semaines
que je vais pas une nouvelle donc oui ça
faisait à l'époque bertrand vous le
voyez pas beaucoup hein à cette époque
là et depuis
depuis un an depuis qu'il a rencontré
marie bertrand on voit très très peu il
est parti de bordeaux
il a quitté sa femme ses enfants son
groupe sa ville sa famille ses amis il
est vraiment parti suivre mari alors il
vous dit
jpm dit
je suis en train de prendre la route
pour partir en vacances je sais sur
france info et j'ai entendu une nouvelle
i apparemment il serait arrivé quelque
chose à marie tu devras lui mets ta
radio et comme je suis dans l'île de ré
qu'on capte mal je suis obligé
d'attendre une demi-heure les chais sur
les grands donc j'ai pas la crème pour
avoir un flash / sur france inter ou là
j'apprends aux flashs de 10 heures que
marie trintignant est dans le coma
battu par un ami ensuite à 11 heures
battu par son ami et à midi battu par
bertrand cantat ouais et entre temps à
chaque fois je passe une heure a essayé
de passer des coups de fil j'essaie
d'appeler bertrand évidemment je ne
l'est pas évidemment puisque j'ai appris
par la radio que marie est dans le
comminges et s'est même pas de l'appeler
mari et je passe des coups de fil
j'arrive à avoir personne et sait c'est
une situation vraiment là le monde
s'écroule pour vous vous êtes et d'anti
emplettes mais pour moi j'ai
l'impression de passer sous un rouleau
compresseur mais vraiment alors là le
déchaînement de la presse commence dit
vous notamment le fameux stéphane
boucher du parisien parce que dans la
dépêche afp en anglais il ya écrit drug
et au lieu de traduire sa part
médicaments il traduit sa part drogue
donc là on commence à la construction
alors la première erreur on va lui
accorder sa elle vient pas de lui je
sais pas d'où elle vient mais la fp à un
pigiste à vilnius qui envoie ses dépêche
en anglais à lagence de varsovie où
elles sont traduites pour être renvoyé
sur paris et ensuite diffusé à la presse
alors l'erreur à quel endroit elle se
fait je sais pas je crois pas que ça
soit lui qui la phase le 1er mai alors
après il s'y accroche après cela garde
bien et puis alors ils ont fait 15
tonnes pendant plusieurs semaines là
dessus oui parce qu'après perdition
après il souligne que bertrand on serait
resté des heures sans rien faire alors
que l' enquête n'est pas commencée il a
aucun moyen le savoir ah ben non mais il
est déjà coupable et ça c'est ce qu'on
va voir dans la presse très rapidement
dans beaucoup beaucoup d'organes de
presse il est coupable de toute façon
bien avant qu'il y ait eu la moindre
réflexion qui est qu'il ya eu la moindre
enquête mais la police lituanienne de
toute façon on va procéder exactement de
la même manière puisque ils reçoivent le
matin marie qui est dans un état ll est
dans le coma
là ce que aucun journaliste n'a dit ce
qui n'a pas intéresser la police ce qui
n'a pas intéresser la justice ce qui n'a
intéressé aucun journaliste et c'est
bien malheureux il ya un premier médecin
qui reçoit mari il la trouve dans un
état où il envoie d'abord en toxicologie
mois pour moi ça veut dire quelque chose
c'est plus tard qu'on se rend compte
qu'il faut qu'elle aille en
traumatologie
et dans l'après midi c'est bertrand qui
atterrit à l'hôpital parce qu'il a
essayé de se suicider en absorbant des
djeuns c'est à dire des médicaments et
quand il sort du coma
les policiers les ont une victime
maintenant un coupable qui dit oui je
lui ai donné des gifles le très violente
il a avoué ces banques étaient les
terminaux et pour tout le monde elle est
terminée et après c'est tout noir ou
tout blanc voilà oui alors justement la
part et nadine trintignant que vous
appelez dans votre livre nadine marquant
ouais c'est très très curieux elle signé
c
ses films
nadine marque en tant qu elle était
mariée avec jean louis trintignant et à
partir du moment où elle divorce de jean
louis trintignant elle signe ses films
nadine trintignant alors je ne sais pas
quel est son problème de personnalité
mais pourquoi la plaine nadine marquant
parce que c'est son nom d'accord alors
nadine marquant trintignant donc affirme
que votre frère était coutumier d'un
comportement violent avec les femmes
tout de suite quoi et vous vous dites
jamais je n'ai vu mon frère exercé la
moindre violence contre qui que ce soit
je n'ai jamais vu péter les plombs et l
enquête vous donnera raison finalement à
bâle enquête me donne entièrement raison
alors moi j'ai pas passer ma vie avec
mon frère
on sait pas côtoyer tous les jours à la
jeune mia
cela dit on sait que
il ya eu des enquêteurs privés puis il
ya eu la police française qui a fait des
enquêtes et personne n'a rien rien
retrouvé toutes les ex de bertrand ont
été interrogés
jamais jamais il n'a touché une fille
jamais il n'en a envoyé une l'hôpital et
monsieur kiejman et nadine marquant
continue d'affirmer sa un gars pas là
non plus encore une fois un journaliste
pour dire ça suffit cette histoire il
faudrait un petit peu arrêter de dire
n'importe quoi parce que ça s'appelle de
la diffamation et nous par pardon par
respect par pudeur on n'a pas attaqué en
diffamation ont pour r oui
voilà mais le mal est fait plusieurs
associations dit féministe et certaines
sommités divo tous proclamé de défense
des droits de la femme commence à
multiplier les déclarations vindicatives
contre bertrand cantat et rit jean marie
trintignant en une sorte d'icône une
icône de la lutte des femmes contre
l'oppression machiste
oui ben je pense que
certaines vont un peu vite en besogne
certaines se trompe peut-être
de manière honnête on va dire je pense
que certaines ne se trompe de manière
pas très honnête elle profite elle
profite de la soudaine notoriété
de la notoriété de marie way pour faire
avancer leur cause qui par ailleurs est
tout à fait juste mais ne mélangeons pas
tout si
deux personnes se bagarre et que à la
fin on se rend compte qu'il y en a un
des deux qui est juif c'est pas
forcément un attentat antisémite ouais
voilà d'accord mais votre vrai très
mesuré d'ailleurs xavier je trouve très
pondéré moi j'ai essayé
comment dire tout au long de cette année
même un peu plus j'ai eu vraiment des
moments de colère je passais par un peu
tous les sentiments du moment une colère
des moments de découragement mais
je veux plus âgés essayé à chaque fois
que j'apporte que je pointe du doigt
quelque chose qui à mon sens ne convient
pas j'essaie de le justifier de la
réglementer j'essaie de ne pas rester
confie dans la colère comme d'autres
restent confident la haine alors voilà
là commence la réécriture de la tragédie
de vilnius la réécriture de la
personnalité de maric qui devient
dites-vous une icône immaculé irradiant
de lumière enfin c'est une sorte de
béatification
alors que vous dites et c'est de
notoriété publique elle avait choisi une
vie un peu bohème elle cultivait un
certain désordre affectif et elle était
capable de sérieuses excès tout le monde
le sait
honnêtement je ne comprends pas le
besoin d'eux
de dire des choses qui sont fausses
parce que on dit là l'idée c'est de
noircir du papier que noircir du papier
avec des choses qui ne sont pas fausses
le gard aucune raison d'inventer des
histoires alors il ya eu une belle
manipulation médiatique de la part
deux pièges man trintignant
associé au groupe hachette filipacchi
télé 7 jours paris match elle fayard qui
publie le dieu bouquin de nadine et
à partir de là bon dès le début on a
match qui titre battu à mort pour mary
et
bon je crois que c'est de toute façon
c'est beaucoup plus facile d'être
fainéant et de voir le monde en noir et
blanc et pas chercher la palette de gris
qui est très riche entre les deux alors
là vous partez à vilnius pour rencontrer
votre frère bertrand et vous dites on a
passé notre temps à pleurer quoi c'était
bertrand et répéter on sait mais
tellement c'est moi tellement mal à tous
qu'il était capable de faire
physiquement
c'était
là oui on s'est serré très fort dans les
bras l'un l'autre et
vous dites j'ai trouvé une loque
terrassé par la souffrance brûlés de
l'intérieur par sa descente aux enfers
oui complètement complètement mais
vraiment complètement anéantie et est
aujourd'hui aussi il est il et il a à
peine évolué quoi enfin disons
aujourd'hui il a compris qu'il fallait
qu'ils restent en vie mais la nuée
intellectuellement on va dire mais de
manière sensible au fond de lui il a
toujours une seule envie c'est rejoindre
marie là où elle est si elle est quelque
part parce que lui-même ne s'explique
toujours pas son geste ne le pardonne
pas
et
il vit dans le manque de marie en
permanence en permanence c'est vraiment
ça ça ça continue de le brûler de
l'intérieur alors votre famille refuse
de polémiquer
de communiquer avec la presse ce qui
fait que la presse s'énerve un peu
contre contre vous et je dirais à
fortiori contre bertrand cantat et
sanctifie encore marie et vous dites
elle n'est pas devenue une sainte parce
qu'elle est une victime oui le fait
d'être une victime et de fait mari est
victime c'est clair net s'est entendu il
n'y a pas à discuter là dessus c'est pas
pour ça qu'il faut réinventer sa vie
alors sa vie vous en parlait d'ailleurs
vous parlez de querelle qui a eu à
l'époque
notamment avec qui elle a vécu et d'un
accident de voiture qu'il l'avait amené
à subir une opération de chirurgie
esthétique
suite à une conduite en état d'ivresse
qui avait motivé le retrait de son
permis de conduire vous parlez de
liaisons amoureuses orageuse enfin une
vie vers normalement voilà pas la sainte
que la presse a voulu décrire ah oui non
qui se fait absolument pas lui rendre
hommage en plus je crois de la part de
sa mère de vouloir en faire une petite
fille modèle ce qu'elle n'a jamais été
dans son livre encore une fois elle
parle
nadine marquants dont sedan dans son
bouquin là elle parle soit d'une petite
fille de six ans soit d'une gamine de
de 15 ans qui est un contre sens premier
son premier amoureux la
bombe et non c'était pas ce rêve marie
elle a eu plein d'âme ans elle a eu
quatre enfants avec quatre pères
différents et non pas 3 ce que semblent
oublier justement encore une fois
monsieur kezman et la famille
trintignant il y en a un dont on ne
parle jamais c'est interdit de séjour à
la maison totalement internet séjour il
ya eu une procédure nadine marquant
essaie de nous faire croire que marie
est toujours resté en bons termes avec
ses ex c'est absolument faux mais bon ça
arrive à plein de gens ça c'est pas
forcément un problème ils essaient de
nous faire croire que jamais ils nous
l'ont vu s'énerver après quelqu'un se
fâcher ben je sais pas ils n'ont pas vu
alors en tous les cas alors pour vous
finalement le dérapage n'est pas
unilatéral c'est à dire qu'il ya eu il
ya eu bagarre lui a dit plusieurs fois
vachette à femmes dites vous à lui a
donné le premier coup de poing et
ensuite il ya une bagarre qui s'est mal
terminée mais vous dites bien vous votre
version des faits j'imagine que c'est
celle que votre frère bertrand cantat
vous a donné c'est une bagarre qui a
dégénéré mais c'est pas lui qui l'a
frappé sans qu'elle réagisse ouais alors
c'est la version qui va donner mais
c'est la version qu'il a toujours donné
aux enquêteurs aussi et là encore une
fois monsieur kezman n'a jamais été
repris par aucun journaliste alors que
plusieurs fois il a menti
en disant que
bertrand changé de version à chaque
déclaration ce qui est totalement faux
au contraire la première fois qu'il a
été interrogé il était encore à moitié
dans le coma il a été interrogé par la
police lituanienne contre avis médical
sans assistance juridique et sa
déclaration elle est toujours restée la
même il a toujours dit voilà comment ça
s'est passé
je lui ai donné des gifles violente très
violente au moins quatre il a toujours
dit ça en revanche quelqu'un qui a varié
à chaque déclaration c'est vincent
trintignant et âme à un journaliste qui
l'a noté à chaque fois sa déclaration a
varié effectivement bertrand raconte
l'histoire comme ça alors il n'y a pas
de témoins moi je voilà donc mon idée
dans le livre c'est pas de dire comme le
fond boucher vézard eux dans leur voilà
ce qui s'est passé on va vous le dire
nous on le sait non moi j étais pas
personnes liées t on à une histoire
c'est on a une version de l'histoire
c'est celle de bertrand elle est vraie
elle est fausse ça je ne sais pas mais
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
n'a jamais varié d'un pouce et ce qui
est regrettable c'est qu'on ne puisse
pas admettre l'idée que ça soit la femme
qui s'énerve la première verbalement et
même physiquement et pourtant ça existe
oui ça existe on le sait
voilà ça peut arriver dix ans mais bien
sûr que ça peut arriver ça arrive
beaucoup moins souvent qu'il y ait des
mort d'homme frappé par une femme que l'
inverse on est entièrement d'accord
aussi n'en parle pas de statistiques là
là on parle d'une histoire ils ont vécu
à deux ensembles de personnalité
tourmentée extrêmes qui ont vécu un
amour fou et là je prends je crois que
justement l'expression moi j'aime pas
tellement les expressions toutes faites
mais cette expression l' amour fou je
pense qu'elle peut convenir là alors la
meilleure preuve en tous les cas de ce
que vous dites c'est que bertrand avait
des blessures ouvertes à la lèvre et
puis des ecchymoses donc il s'est fait
tout seul oui ça a été noté
par par les médecins tout ça ça a été
consigné alors là on entre en piste une
vedette de la chanson qui s'appelle lio
vous parler d'elle en disant c'est une
ex 2000 vedette de la variété française
des années 80 vous êtes en colère bah
y'a de quoi parce qu'elle a un peu
repris elle le dit elle même elle est
montée au créneau parce que nadine lui a
demandé quelle est en service commandé
elle s'auto proclame meilleure amie de
marie
ouais encore une fois c'est bien dommage
que marie soit pas là pour répondre
bon ça va dire quelle copine moi et pour
lio qui a refusé d'en parler ici mais
elle est elle en parlait le lendemain
chez sept à huit sur tf1 pour lions en
tous les cas c'est pas une c'est pas une
histoire d'amour leur histoire c'est une
histoire de destruction c'est lui qui
voulait la briser elle voit ça vraiment
dans ce sens là oui elle voit ça dans ce
sens là enfin je ne sais pas si elle le
voit vraiment ou aussi ça l'arrangé
juste pour se refaire une petite santé
médiatique
mais
elle n'y était pas n'était pas elle est
la seule à témoigner du fait qu' on
voyait marie tout le temps malheureuse
alors que tout le monde témoigne du fait
qu'on les voyait très amoureux tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps tous
les deux et je crois qu'elle confond et
en plus elle est très bien placé pour
savoir qu'on peut vivre longtemps avec
un castagneur puisque elle même ça a
duré très longtemps son histoire avec le
type qu'elle a réussi à faire condamner
elle le sait très bien qu'il a frappé
parce qu'il la frappait il l'a violée et
elle l'a fait condamner et c'est très
très bien et c'est normal mais donc
c'est bien la preuve qu'on peut rester
un moment on part pas à la première
gifle donc quand elle parle de
l'histoire de marié de bertrand je crois
qu'elle confond avec son histoire à elle
vous mettez en doute les qualités
morales de llo pour s'ériger en arbitre
des élégances sur la sphère de votre
frère effectivement oui c'est pas
seulement ses qualités morales mais
c'est je crois qu'elle est pas l est pas
l est pas bien placé c'était absolument
pas la meilleure amie de marie
la preuve elle dit elle-même mari ne
m'avait pas dit avec qui avec qui elle
était 1 parce qu'on va pas le dire à la
voisine s'il sait pas sa meilleure amie
alors vous raconter un épisode qui est
beaucoup moins glorieux pour la famille
quant à ces la soirée hommage à vilnius
dans un bistrot qui s'appelle le café le
pari
donc la musique de noir désir projection
d'un film avec marie trintignant et puis
c'est un lieu public
à ce moment là des gens viennent pour
fêter un anniversaire ils sont filmés en
même temps que vous et ça se termine
dans vsd avec un titre la fête de la
honte alors ça se termine pas que dans
vsd ça se termine par tous avec ce genre
de titre c'est la fête de la honte ils
ont dansé sur le corps de marie etc etc
c'est alors là c'est une vraie
manipulation quoi le café le pari dépend
du centre culturel français qui est lui
même dépendant de l'ambassade de france
ne s'est pas n'importe quel bar branché
de la ville comme certains journalistes
l'ont écrit c'est à deux pas du lieu du
drame allez à vilnius vous verrez que
tout est à deux pas du lieu du drame
c'est aussi un café ouvert c'est pas
seulement réservé aux français et il ya
des gens qui ont réservé une table au
fond il ya de quoi faire deux rangées de
tables il ya une rangée de tables avec
des gens qui tirent la gueule en
écoutant du noir désir et en regardant
betty le film de chabrol et une rangée
de tables avec des gens qui font la fête
ils sont lituaniens ne connaissent pas
ils s'en fichent la musique ils
connaissent pas ils s'en fichent ils
font la fête ils train qui dansent et
ils boivent des coûts et les
journalistes qui viennent film ces gens
alors vous avez dit il les filme en même
temps qu'eux
que ma famille ou les proches il les
filme pas en même temps il les films
complètement à part et ils prennent dans
laxe des gens qui boivent qui font la
fête qui se fiche royalement des images
qui passent projetées sur le mur et en
disant voilà c'est c'est une fête
honteuse et or c'est une manipulation de
la part de journalistes lituaniens qui
ont vendu ça à des journalistes français
parce qu'il ya des journalistes des
organes de presse français capable
d'acheter ça s'il n'y avait pas
d'acheteur il n'y aurait pas de vendeurs
savent où vous l'avez dit souvent et
comme par hasard la presse ne s'est
jamais fait l'écho dites-vous tchaboré
jamais jamais jamais ça n'a été repris
jamais ça d'ailleurs été repris fait
alors que tous les journalistes il ya
des dizaines et des dizaines de
journalistes qui sont passés à vilnius
ils sont venus voir les lieux ouais
forcément ils sont venus voir les lieux
ils ont vu la configuration ils ont vu
comment ça s'est passé ils le savent
très bien et par contre on a bien repris
les propos de pièges man encore une fois
dix ans c'est bon je sais plus les
termes exacts enfin il trouvé ça
scandaleux qu'on montre mari dans le
rôle d'une alcoolique on n'a pas dit que
marie était alcoolique marie elle était
actrice joue le rôle d'une alcoolique
dans ce film est un film magnifique est
un film que la critique unanime à saluer
et le film et la prestation de marie si
c'est pas lui rendre hommage que de
montrer l'un de ses plus beaux rôles en
plus cette idée de soirée hommage est
pas une idée avoue à la famille quandt
assez l'idée d'un gendarme qui travaille
pour l'ambassade de france donc en plus
voilà mais oui qui lui un pensée lui
c'est un élan du coeur il vous on sait
faire bien il pensait faire bien bon
alors résultat tout ça quand même
menaces téléphoniques
lettres d'insultés et finalement
incendie de la maison de bertrand cantat
votre frère avec sa femme cristina quand
même c'est beaucoup voyez quelques jours
après un incendie criminel on met le feu
à leurs maisons alors maison des landes
alors que cette nuit là
la femme de bertrand et ses enfants
auraient dû être dans la maison
heureusement soir là ils sont passés
chez moi ils en sont partis assez tard
ils étaient fatigués sont restés à
bordeaux et ils sont pas partis dans la
maison ouais en tout cas c'était le 11
septembre
plus d'un an après
on n'a pas trouvé les coupables mais je
me demande si on les a cherchés ouais
moi je pense que pour trouver on a plus
de chance hier si on cherchait et par
exemple je n'accuse personne mais il se
trouve que on est
dans cette affaire on a des adversaires
et j'ai pas dans n'importe quelle
téléfilm que pourrait écrire
démarquant par exemple s'il y avait une
partie lésée et ensuite un acte criminel
commis contre ce qu'on pense coupable on
interrogerait la partie lésée où
étiez-vous que faisiez-vous ce soir là
ouais
moi je veux pas accuser mais le meilleur
moyen d'avoir des réponses et poser les
questions vous avez jamais lus et là
dessus ils ont jamais été interrogé
absolument pas ça normal ni vous ni eux
n'ont personne
voilà et pilar arrive le livre de nadine
trintignant nadine marco comme vous
dites alors là vous dites la furie et
elle est à longueur de pages dans marie
ma fille nous a anéantis cette violence
ce mépris cette volonté d'encrasser
bertrand et d'influencer la justice
elle l'a dit elle même ma volonté c'est
influencer la justice elle l'a dit elle
même donc elle se permet tout elle
réinvente
complètement la vie de marie la vie de
bertrand et puis elle se met carrément
hors la loi en le traitant 85 x de
meurtriers ce qui veut dire meurtrier
qui lie à tuer vous qu'il aurait tué
volontairement et deux fois d'assassins
ce qui voudrait dire avec préméditation
c'est parfaitement illégal et là on
tombe sur une juge qui dit il faut
comprendre la douleur d'une mère pour
moi comprendre la douleur d'une mère je
veux bien
ça n'autorise pas tout et n'importe quoi
pour autant enfin une juge qui ne dit
pas le droit à qui on s'en remet alors
oui c'est quand même un livre qui s'est
vendu à 300 mille exemplaires oui mais
voilà il ya des gens qu'on
drôle de goût ce que vous faites
remarquer xavier ces camps annexes elle
reproduit la correspondance qu'elle a
eue avec marie trintignant oumar et
radiant s'exprime sur sa sexualité sa
vie amoureuse moi à titre personnel je
trouve ça carrément indécent ouais
là vous faites lire le livre à votre
frère
oui petit à petit ouais petit à petit
parce qu'on veut pas cesser cette
sainte est le concentré de de haine et
je suis vraiment désolé parce que moi
dans ce livre je leur dis moi la douleur
d'une mère je veux évidemment évidemment
que je la comprends je la vois pas du
tout dans ce livre à aucune douleur dans
ce livre aucune n'y a que de la haine et
c'est du pur concentré et ce sont des
inventions des mensonges elle dit
qu'elle ne sait pas pourquoi bertrand
débarque à vilnius alors qu'elle lui a
proposé un rôle
le rôle que lambert wilson joue elle
avait d'abord proposé à bertrand s'il
vient c'est à la demande de marie les
enfants elle dit que les enfants de
marie ne sont pas restés le temps prévu
c'est absolument faux et là il aurait
suffi que n'importe quel enquêteurs
aille vérifier les dates des billets
d'avion les dates d'entrée et de sortie
de l'hôtel il aurait vu que il était
resté le temps prévu et c'est bertrand
qui s'en occuper parce que marielle baus
et du matin au soir toute la journée
elle était épuisée alors votre frère
quand il dit ça c'est terrible parce
qu'il y ait un livre où il y des
mensonges concernant la vie récente
c'était un prix mais s'est vendu à 300
mille exemplaires et lui peut même pas
répondre et lui peut pas répondre non il
attendrait il n'a pas droit il n'a pas
droit à une réponse donc il est vraiment
il est vraiment effondré et en même
temps on lui dit ben voila tu vois ça tu
peux pas laisser faire ça ça tu peux pas
laisser faire et pour tes enfants il
faut que tu restes en vie pour que les
enfants mais même ceux de marie un jour
ils sachent la vérité et la vérité moi
je suis désolé pour les enfants de marie
mais c'est pas leur grand-mère qui va la
leur apprendre alors dans ce livre
nadine trintignant insinue que bertrand
s'est enfui de l'hôpital aussitôt après
avoir déposé marie trintignant est en
fait pas du tout il a été chassé par 26
chassé par vincent c'est ce que déclare
vincent lui-même de toute façon
c'est vincent qui l'a chassé qui l'a
empêché de rester voilà et puis arrive
le procès et puis d'autres procès à
l'horizon parce que ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que les galères sont à terminer
puisque au delà du procès qui voit votre
frère en prison il ya l'assurance du
téléfilm colette qui était tourné à
vilnius qui veut se rembourser qui
cherchent l'argent évidemment ils
résident des demandes de dommages et
intérêts des enfants de marie
trintignant
ces grosses j'emmerde encore on n'est
pas sorti de du drame un loin de là bien
sûr
effectivement il y a
l'assureur du producteur qui a fait
bloquer les comptes de
de bertrand
en
des factures complètement aberrante mais
ça va mettre longtemps à être jugé sur
le fond mais c'est n'importe quoi
ça a coûté une fortune les deux derniers
jours de tournage qui n'ont pas eu lieu
une fortune ce qui est étonnant c'est
moi j'ai jamais vu un assureur payé
rubis sur l'ongle comme ça à 3 francs
près ce que ce que son client lui de lui
eric trouve ça magnifique moi je sais
que je vais m'assurer chez lui
maintenant il va tout payer et
maintenant ils vous demandent et voilà
on paye tout c'est génial et maintenant
ils contre attaquent et pareil on bloque
tout acte ou alors qu'on ne juge pas du
tout elle a de la qualité de la demande
il ya une demande ok on bloque voilà
alors il ya un moment vous écrivez je ne
suis pas croyant je suis même plutôt un
bouffeur de curé ouais mais l'âge
implore le ciel quand même mais il ya
des moments on a envie
le fam le ciel plus tôt les curés
jeunesse et des curés quand même mais
oui il ya des moments on a envie de deux
dates de recevoir lens et padoue quoi
qu'il puisse venir de quelque part
puisqu'on la voit venir de nulle part
l'inde a envie on cherche vers le haut
qui vous a aidé en tout cette épreuve
beaucoup de gens alors que ce soit clair
ce livre c'est mon livre c'est ma parole
c'est ma pensée c'est mon expression ce
sont mes idées mes réflexions je suis
pas le porte parole de bertrand je ne
suis pas le porte-parole de noir désir
je ne suis pas le porte parole de la
famille quant à je ne suis pas le porte
parole du groupe qui s'est constitué
pour
aider à la défense de bertrand qui était
constitué de mes parents ma soeur moi
même la femme de bertrand son meilleur
ami sa meilleure amie et les trois
autres membres du groupe noir désir
voilà on était une dizaine tous on a
reçu de l'aide de de tous nos de tous
nos proches de tous les gens qu'on a
rencontrés moi je n'ai vraiment
rencontré personne personne personne ni
dans nos métiers n'est ni à l'école de
mes gamins ni ni dans la rue on a reçu
des dizaines et des dizaines de
courriers de soutien pour nous aider à
traverser ce que les gens considèrent
comme une épreuve terrible pour nous
aussi alors je viens pas pour me
plaindre je viens pas faire pleurer dans
les chaumières sinon je me serais fait
éditer ailleurs si j'avais voulu faire
un livre uniquement pour dire pour nous
aussi c'est très dur mais
il est très digne votre bouquin il se
trouve que oui il est digne il y en a
encore pour qu'en même temps on bertrand
il a été condamné à huit ans il a fait
un an presque et demi compte tenu des
remises de peine automatiques
il doit lui rester
entre 4 ans et 4 ans et demi et
ce qui fera
oui voila je prends je pense qu'en tout
compte tenu des remises de peine
automatiques
ça devrait faire cinq ans et demi au
final à peu près
après peut-être qu'il y aura
les amnisties du 14 janvier qui freine
et quinze jours des choses comme ça et
puis à partir de la mi peine
il peut faire une demande de libération
conditionnelle merci il faut être sûr de
ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux